welcome to a special episode of tech
news briefing for Monday April 3rd I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
you've probably been hearing a lot about
artificial intelligence AI seems to be
everywhere these days Google meta slash
Facebook Microsoft are in a race to
introduce new artificial intelligence
systems the AI race for for search it's
on the artificial intelligence Company
open AI unveiled chat gpt4 it's the
photo editing app that's taken over
social media lenza AI it's not the first
time AI has promised to shake up our
world but something about this moment
does seem to be different generative AI
is changing the game and maybe a lot of
other things too
we are Tech news briefing wanted to know
more so we've launched this series
airing Mondays in April called
artificially minded to look at what's
new now and what it means for ai's
future and our own
but first to understand what's going on
with artificial intelligence and
generative AI we need to start with some
Basics because how AI works and what it
can do is complicated So today we're
going back to school
joining me to break down AI 101 is wsj
science reporter Eric neeler hey Eric
thanks for joining me hey it's great to
be with you so I want to deal with the
basics today when we talk about AI what
do we even mean sure well artificial
intelligence has been around for a while
it started out more as a statistical
kind of method for making decisions with
computers and over time of course it's
evolved but really when we talk about AI
it's any kind of technology that can
reason learn plan and make decisions you
know these are all tasks that normally
require human intelligence but something
else or someone else is doing it and
that's artificial intelligence
I feel like another term that I'll often
hear when we talk about artificial
intelligence is machine learning can you
tell us what that is and how it relates
sure machine learning is a form of AI
form of artificial intelligence and
instead of being programmed to do a
specific thing maybe check the
temperature and give a reading or go and
search for a couple things and come back
it can actually learn to do a specific
task on its own it's learning by
figuring out patterns in data and also
inference if this is so then this must
be so if we add these two things
together so examples of machine learning
for example Uber and other car sharing
apps use this to predict the demand for
drivers and passengers and also machine
learning is also used in the medical
field to identify and predict cancer
tumors by looking at Medical scans maybe
early detection of these tumors or
medical problems so it is just learning
the way we would learn you know if if
one thing happens then another thing
might happen is that right yeah imagine
associate and there are also different
ways you can train an algorithm an
algorithm is like a little program right
so you can train it with reinforcement
you did a good job here's a little stick
or you get more data for your training
and when we talk about training these
programs
need big amounts of data so example
let's say a facial recognition program
in order to get it accurate you're going
to need large numbers of people's faces
so that the program can tell differences
and it can make matches and so forth or
if the program is designed to look at
Medical scans for example the larger
number it has to get trained on the more
accurate it's going to be so the
training happens first and then once
it's the person that's written this
program feels that it's accurate enough
then it's going to do it on its own if
we're thinking about the generative AI
tools that people maybe have tried out
now is this kind of how something like
chat GPT learns to respond I'm fine when
you ask how it's doing yeah it's funny
what chat GPT does is look at vast
amounts of text and it sort of learns
from that text it assimilates this into
something called a law large language
model this is another form of AI that is
employed by chat GPT so it doesn't have
knowledge like we do in our brains but
it has the ability to process language
really fast and really deep ways of
making associations between your
question and maybe a question that's
been asked somewhere else or something
it's read in a book or on a website to
come up with an answer
so just like students it's learning you
know what's in books so we can respond
with them it's getting treats like
stickers or whatever the computer
equivalent is of a sticker If you get
something right in school Eric another
term that I feel like I've heard
associated with artificial intelligence
is neural network what is that so our
brain is made up of neurons that are
connected brain cells right and it does
processing it doesn't do it from the top
down it sort of has these little places
where processing happens with language
with mathematics with music with faces
and so a neural network is a computer
program that sort of mimics that so a
neural network can identify images
patterns text facial expressions by
working on several levels and also
several nodes of processing and again
that's why they use the term neural
network because it's a little bit like
how our brain works a lot of people will
have heard of potentially tried out chat
GPT or maybe an air generator there's
more and more options for people to try
their hand at this but AI has been
around for a while can you just tell us
some places that we might have
interacted with it just in our daily
lives that we haven't thought about
sure there's some very simple things
apps that we use on our phone to to get
us places navigation apps the Google
search bar they're also you know when
delivery drivers have to make their
routes making the best route most
efficient way there are other places too
where it's being used by law firms that
are needing to search massive amounts of
cases of case law for example to find
references to find applicable language
used to be clerks would do this or
paralegals and now they're sophisticated
AI machine learning tools that can go
through years of digitized cases and
legal proceedings to get just the right
answer to file in your brief and that's
got some people worried too
so it's out there it's being used I
think the most important things are that
we understand it and also the people
that are making these programs
understand the human element what are
they trying to do how are these
algorithms affecting people
okay in a moment we'll continue our AI
101 conversation with Eric neeler but
first we asked people on the streets of
downtown San Francisco how they felt
about AI
how do you feel about artificial
intelligence
I think it's necessary
that simple I I know that everybody's
scared about it
um because it's
we hold knowledge in our brains and so
if something can replace that then we
are very replaceable I honestly like it
I think it's very
[Music]
um
it's just an innovation and they think
it's very important it's helping
improving a lot of fields and a lot of
companies so I think it's important to
work on it right now both optimistic
skeptical
this moment in AI feels different from
developments in the past I'm back with
wsj science reporter Eric nealer Eric a
lot of what we've been talking about are
artificial intelligence abilities that
have already existed and that have been
integrated into our day-to-day lives but
we're seeing a lot more about AI in the
past few months so what's different
about this current moment than what
we've seen over the past few years I
think what's happened just in the last
six months or so is the introduction of
these large language models the chat GPT
for example that just has some
remarkable human-like abilities to
answer our questions to write memos to
make what we think could be opinions
about other people or world events or
Twitter for example and this is just
kind of shaken us I think a lot of us
because it has appeared to be some kind
of new being or new Force when it's
really just more of a repetitive kind of
thing it's a technology that's learning
from text and responding with texts that
it learns and you know I I just was
seeing this on Twitter remember chatgpt
is not a knowledge model it's a language
model and what that means is that it
doesn't know things it's repeating
things
it seems like what we're realizing now
is that there are quite a lot of risks
with artificial intelligence can you
take us through what some of the big
ones are you know I think the everyday
risks are things about accuracy bias in
facial recognition also another risk is
that there's a failure in system
something that hasn't been thought up
before by the programmer it's important
to realize though that the risks are
all within sort of a structure in the
sense that the programmer is telling the
AI where it can work what it can do the
data that it has to use
these are you know in many ways the
researchers I've talked to and
interviewed say these are manageable
risks to solve these problems or to
reduce these risks we need more data to
train on in order to eliminate or reduce
the risk of mistaken identity for
example in facial recognition you need
better lighting better images more
images using training sets with more
black and brown faces for example
that'll help that algorithm make better
facial recognition decisions
the risks though that we often talk
about can also be this
sort of existential risk that AI is
going to take over the risks that are
identified in Hollywood films and on
science fiction books about AI sort of
going beyond the boundaries of what the
programmer tells it to do or the
training set that it's using so far we
really haven't seen that and I don't
think that's going to happen anytime
soon to be honest are there any rules or
laws about how AI can be used or cannot
be used
here in the United States there really
aren't that many rules governing AI we
have seen it attempts to restrict or
limit its use by law enforcement
agencies in various states and cities on
our federal level no we're not seeing it
in fact many federal agencies are
expanding their use of AI facial
recognition Technologies to say limit
access to buildings to make
determinations on you know employees and
so forth we are however seeing some sort
of move to regulate AI in Europe there
are much more concerns there and they've
put in some new rules just in the last
couple years we're going to see how that
filters down how that affects businesses
and of course how it affects society and
the people that use AI all right that's
wsj science reporter Eric nealer thanks
for joining us for this conversation
Eric thanks very much
okay that's it for this first episode of
our series artificially minded join us
next Monday when we'll answer questions
submitted by you on artificial
intelligence until then you can catch
regular episodes of tech news briefing
for the rest of the week and if you want
more Tech news check out our website
wsj.com Today's show was produced by
Julie Chang our supervising producer is
Melanie Roy and our executive producer
is Chris sinsley this show was mixed by
Michael LaValle and I'm your host Zoe
Thomas thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you